oh cool Warner's Disney fiying their
logos to match the movies context -
please tell me that they'll sign off
with a super posh version of Porky Pig
saying a video that's old sport also far
too many seconds of these old timey
logos my younger and more vulnerable
years I was clearly tempted to start a
movie by using a lazy trope of
voice-over narration back then all of us
drank too much back then and none of us
contributed anything new youtubers only
one man was exempt from my disgust
Gatsby roll gaze he was the single most
hopeful person I've ever met you
obviously never met the dog from up dude
I don't care if it is the 1920s there's
no way you'd be able to walk around a
psychiatric hospital with a tie it's
dangerous and definitely sinful at a
party in New York this is supposed to be
older wiser more tired and more seasoned
Nick long after the events were about to
see he honestly looks like about 1.5
years older basically the same only he
missed a few showers it's at this point
that the movie pans into 1922 Manhattan
while playing a jay-z song and I am
already out on the blatant anachronism
zuv this movie I haven't even needed
does it add anything that is moving can
you not just set it in present-day
stocks reached record Peaks and Wall
Street food and steady gold narration
they could have called this movie
pressing my buttons a gentleman I had
not yet met he was your neighbor my
neighbor we've established the fact that
Gatsby was his neighbor no need to say
it over and over and over like it's some
kind of old sport or something she lived
across the bay
old-money East Egg and welcome to Yan
the movie seriously Baz Luhrmann
directed this tale of opulence and he's
never done a movie there hasn't felt
like it was on PCP but this still came
out as a boring mess it's pretty but
much like Tobey Maguire that's all
what's got going for it
my little shacks just a cardboard box at
80 a month your life is adorable I know
somebody in West - Jesus Christ the
scene seriously feels like an audition
when the actors are reading the script
for the first time you must know Gatsby
Gatsby
what can't speak Malkovich Malkovich
Malkovich I have no goddamn clue about
why Baez Lerman gets such a pass on his
editing style there are like four times
more unnecessary cuts in this scene
alone then a standard MCU fight scene
and that's saying a lot
the idea is it's up to us the dominant
race watch out or these other races well
man was totally racist back in the 20s
there's no way this conversation would
happen between several rich white people
almost 100 years later right right
excuse me right back anyone that says
this while closing doors to keep their
upcoming conversation private while
smoking a cigar is definitely a cheating
evil ticket and die ass and nurse if it
was a boy or girl and Carey Mulligan
Michelle Williams is so hard in this
movie that I'm half convinced I'm
watching at Dawson's Creek episode fun
fact this movie was originally a stealth
prequel to Green Lantern in darkest
night when I write about anything
whatever brings you ease I suggest you
write Ulysses fanfiction keep your story
the same but change the character's
names and make them really into bondage
sex I promise this formula works
[Music]
kids the only way these two could be
more obviously King as if they showed
actual penetration right now person sits
quietly alone outside a room where his
friends are loudly boning in a movie
cliche watch this single line of
dialogue does there's a lot more
exploration than it will receive weird
you urging where do I get them from
attacked in Queens your walkway oh no my
nerves are fine thanks I see Bill
Cosby's grandmother grew up on Long
Island and this is the most be t13 orgy
I've seen sensitive Lander I was
listening and without if you took out
all the near writing in this movie it
would be 30 minutes shorter Boyer ism'
put it seriously I've killed this movie
to put in some jazz it was the Rory
goddamn 20s man which was an excellent
time for music well we simply have to
talk about how Moulin Rouge I Gatsby's
parties are Eris's comparing
inheritances embellishing my elegance
and eloquence the elephant is in the
room the truth is in your face what up
sorry sorry Hamilton strikes again right
bad I decided to get roaring drunk hey
that's what I decided too after watching
the first few minutes of this movie
nobody who would he do I remember to
live next door and I remember the
Cloverfield paradox here has an
extremely volatile southern accent that
only appears when she's trying to say
something seductive who is this Gatsby
he was a German spy discount are we
hammered priced more dancing you know
there's steeping the audience in the
lavish Gatsby lifestyle and then there's
drowning them in it I'm not gonna play
the music here but I can guaran-damn-tee
you that none of it is being produced by
these instruments look around you rich
girls don't marry poor boys guess what
the hostility here sure Teddy's drunk
but he knows nothing about Nick
circumstances at least according to the
movie was this the face that launched a
thousand gifts and burnt the topless
towers of Twitter sweetly Oh make me a
mobile with a martini also one of the
reasons this movie is 2 hours and 22
minutes long is that it takes 30 minutes
for the title character to show up
[Music]
Rhapsody and Hugh glass the movie makes
it seem like these types of parties
happen all the time but like this who
the hell would live out in West Egg if
their neighborhood turns into a war zone
every night doing this are things about
to get erotic up in here cuz I could
murder some Gatsby Carraway fanfic also
given the status of the night lighting
here there's no way Jay would be able to
see Nick from all the way up there
well we rode in the hydroplane and I
attended two more of his parties we'd
already blown too much of our production
budget to film any of that though yet
trust
Lorna lunch it takes NIC so long to even
question Gatsby's motives that I'm
nominating him for doofus of the year of
course 1922 was also the year Stalin was
installed as general secretary so seems
there were doofuses aplenty to vie for
the prize that year after that I lived
like some prince and all the capitals of
Europe I swear to God eNOS of the ADR in
this movie is only rivaled by like
Battlefield Earth every allied
government gave me a map why would a guy
go mystery and suspense for months on
end and then suddenly pick this one dude
and turn into bragging Brad and don't
preys on himself for this entire Drive
if Gatsby has an angle and it's working
Nick for the specific purpose of getting
to Nick's cousin which he is then why is
he so wildly shifting in approaches
right you are Gatsby's a thing but this
in New York City even Giuliani after
9/11 couldn't get out of a ticket just
by showing his business card I don't
care if the police commissioner is in
his pocket you think that trickled down
to the beat cops I was able to do the
commission of a favor once sends me a
Christmas card every year huh I was able
to do a commission or a favor once and
all I get every year is an annual
flare-up what by the time we reach the
bridge I was impossibly confused as am i
from listening to this jay-z song not
only is an Akron it is completely out of
nowhere in terms of this between movie
but this is Mickey day right I
understand there were speakeasies and
stuff during Prohibition but that
happened mostly at night I know I
discovered a man of fine breeding
suckish a meadow such metals solo Oxford
Tom funny seeing you extremely funny
seeing Tom considering the size of this
city and the time of day Daisy and
Gatsby why I don't quite know where to
start but you will start soon know what
over 45 minutes in here and it's
literally all been set up the way he
looked at her the way all girl
by Leonardo DiCaprio Daisy Fay married
Tom Buchanan with more pomp and
circumstance than Louisville had ever
seen even bigger than Secretariat the
brown hotel the first batch of bourbon
Muhammad Ali and Rick Pitino combined
thank you nice dude isn't Nick poor he
just took a cab from Times Square to
Long Island which should cost if my
conversion to 1920s dollars is correct
roughly $6,000 not since Jim and
American Wedding as a guy believed so
hard that landscaping would help him
with the lady he loves the director had
an argument with the actual character of
Jay Gatsby over exactly how many flowers
constituted too many Gatsby won the
argument mostly because the septic
Raider had taken the day off to go to a
scrapbooking convention and wasn't
around to break the top you got
everything you need perhaps more flowers
Nick would be excellent at cinemasins if
he worked even better at kissing
Gatsby's ass this Gatsby is rich but
he's also human and in waiting for Daisy
he shows his true colors and a good way
goes on for some time
did you ransack a green house he is in
love with me can we please address how
casually this incestuous implication is
so goddamn casual painting panting Jesus
how long has Gatsby been standing there
waiting on the tea he was so cuz a
second ago but now he's bone-dry the
movie's main message seems to be that
rich dudes get just as nervous in front
of the girls they love his poor dudes do
some such I don't know even worse I
don't care I know they're intentionally
making this moment awkward but I also
feel like the scene as a metaphor for
this entire goddamn movie walking I'm
the same view from my place casual
admission of stalking notwithstanding
kind of does Daisy not know that Gatsby
lives across the bay from her he's all
anyone talks about and his parties are
epic how did she not see the huge
fucking fireworks show from last week I
realized she was maybe trying to avoid
him but it would be impossible for her
not to know that he's here come with me
and you'll be okay yes but a married
brute this whole thing went from super
nervous about seeing each other to
acting like they're newlyweds very
quickly premature ejaculation
this scene right here perfection I know
I've as on Lerman for his heavy
handedness but this shot of je literally
showering Daisy with riches with too
much exuberance because he's mr. so much
along with her initial joyful reception
that turns to slight sadness just
brilliant once it all I want to show you
something yes the distant cousin of the
you better take a look at this cliche a
lot of clippings I collected about you
um I guess stalking kind of okay as long
as it's done by a super gorgeous
gazillionaire right reminiscing screw
all these pillows goddamn the pillows I
cannot stress enough how there are way
to me holy look at all those candles I
was going all lame ripping the level of
excess on the pillows and the candles
were like hold my beer kale as old as
time this dude down here and putting out
the candles one of the time it's
definitely days away from snapping
listen closely and you can almost hear
him muttering his mantra light the
candles one by one then we snuff them
because it's fun by the time of morning
Sun if we're lucky we'll be done I wish
I'd done everything on earth with you
even snipe honey ain't the iditarod I
wish it could always be like this you
mean like a namelessly meandering
montage of confusing flashbacks and soap
opera scene transitions wrapped in an
auditory volume of a backing score he
lowed out and rescued the vessel and
it's captain alcoholic millionaire dam
Cody dam you gotta admire this dude's
commitment to alcoholism even in the
middle of a shipwreck with that rescue
boat approaching he still makes time for
one more swig from his comically large
wicker drinking vessel this is the
movies Martha why did you say that name
moment but when Cody died Gatsby was
cheated of his inheritance by Cody's
family can you really get cheated out of
something that you have no right or
claim to um why is Tom here again I
thought he had a particular disdain for
the side of the bay and mister steal yo
girl should be hanging with Daisy
without her husband right
I'd really rather not be the polo player
well you're not God you're a polo player
okay you're a polo player
polo player polo player polo player so
whew mr. Buchanan would you mind
terribly
asking another dudes wife to dance I
don't care if you're asking his
permission or whatever rude to all
parties present if you come up to me at
a public event and ask if you can dance
with my wife I will shove a nearby large
object up the hole from which you pee
you what the hell they've had at least
several weeks whence they reconnected
but they wait until the middle of a huge
party attended by Daisy's husband to
finally start the kissy time thing Carey
Mulligan text it to isla Fisher after
the first table read somehow made it
into the movie hello Nick their wheels
so hard in this movie that he might as
well be riding around on a tricycle you
can't repeat the past can't repeat the
past movie thinks this repeated line is
clever but it's just annoying given this
movie is over 2 hours and 22 minutes
long he knew his mind would never again
be freed rom that falling in love would
change his destiny damn it Daisy started
this movie out by having some actual
agency some hooter but halfway through
this mother she's turned into a
starry-eyed swooner that waits patiently
for Jays inner monologues to shut the
fuck up she blossomed for him like a
flower oh I just need to give her more
time once for the one thing this movie
does not need is more fucking time Daisy
visited discreetly what's the issue here
they're back together they obviously
love each other they're humping like
koala bears and he's got all the money
in the world right there may be a social
or family reason keeping Daisy from
leaving Tom but movies much more
interested in showing us some soft focus
softcore than explaining any of that
Gatsby shuts down the parties and starts
screwing Daisy in secret and then what
what's the point of all the lavish
parties again he didn't even reconnect
with her at one of those he leveraged
his neighbor Nick's connection
everything about this story is who can
squirrelly man why did they make me read
this in school I'm not across from you
right there god damn it why do people
continue to treat this as a surprise
it's not like the fucking castle is easy
to miss and Tom has been to the fucking
house
and it will be fun it was your idea fine
have it your own way Tom what the hell
was this scene I know it was supposed to
be building up tension between the two
love interests but this was executed
like a bad high school play would you be
good enough to take my copay and I'll
Drive everyone else in your circus wagon
jealous husband asked the guy he thinks
is building his wife if he can drive his
car and that is putting your hook on the
table wait come on that's not offensive
people used to they used to pull out
there to measure that you're saying they
didn't that was never a thing well I
disagree
and challenge you to a measuring contest
I've made a small investigation
into this fellow and you found he was an
Oxford man there is no can way anyone's
hearing any bit of this conversation
right now the gaps and the spurious ah
sudden Jason Clark that hasn't really
been in this movie at all but will
become crucial to the plot for no reason
at the very end uh man in the pink suit
went to Oxford Tom said I went there
didn't I yes but you didn't address the
pink suit which in my opinion is a
greater offense than lying about
attending a university what kind of a
row are you trying to cause in my house
anyhow he isn't causing a row you're
causing a row Wow how now brown cow
might I interest you in joining this
Ralph
she only married you because I was poor
and she was tired of waiting was maybe
technically true but to not even consult
her on this before doing a public attack
thingy is bad boyfriend material
starting to think she's better off with
cheating tom than with psychopathic
gatsby no what no never Gatsby looked in
that moment as if he had killed a man
this is presented as a big revelation
but he's been to war right if he hadn't
killed someone that would be more
concerning I think he realizes that this
little flirtation held up on that sure
Gatsby lost his temper but this is way
overblown relative to the unrequited
love we've seen and shove down our
retinas this entire movie this marriage
breaking down between the two least
important movie characters since the
kids in Jurassic Park right at this
moment it is among the most obnoxious
coincidences of all film and also all
literature this is about to become some
bolt is what I mean no one will be
seated while the body from Sin City
flies through the air I mean I know it's
the 20s but can any Tom Dick er well Tom
just walk up to the corpse at a crime
scene I saw it was the yellow car big
yellow car
a big yellow taxi because if sorrow we
can implicate both Joni Mitchell and
that dreadlock motherfucker from
Counting Crows all in one fell swoop and
that beer at what color is your car it's
blue coupe a coupe a coupe a pronounced
cool I'm I've been saying it wrong for
43 fucking years
incidentally this is exactly how I feel
at this point of this interminable
fucking movie gonna defend him now ah
nope nick has actually completely
disappeared from this story I know he's
supposed to be more of an ethereal
narrator but he is a real character in
this movie wanted to tell you the whole
story for a very long time in fact I've
waited through almost an entire goddamn
movie before launching into this over
long expository monologue a gift that I
have never found in any other person you
Nick we're swallowing all Gatsby's loads
so thoroughly and fully I haven't used
that pool once all some bull shadowing I
have to go Jay I have to work what there
hasn't been one shot of Nick being
gainfully employed in this whole thing I
I suppose yeah this exchange is the
movie in a nutshell but even am I
supposed to learn since this movie has
more endings than the return of King
King I'll summarize for you Nick says
goodbye Daisy calls Jay gets to capped
and everyone else lives miserably but
fashionably ever after then there's a
bonus montage of footage from the movie
you just watched are you not entertained
don't spoil sports book called foreign
schools roads for Ghost World for older
adults waters which brings will note
those fields old sport words for Osborn
spoon and spoon who knows
don't spot us for hotspots for notes for
those boys bomb squads oil coats boots
world's World Sport sport Sport sport
Sport sport
[Music]
you want to sit on the sidelines and
watch what do you want to play ball it
changes everything I have to dress there
but I have to act different did she love
me when she married me she loves me not
no no and then our children will form a
family band and we will turn the
countryside and you won't be invited
there is no nobility in poverty I've
been a rich man and I have been a poor
man I choose rich every time her husband
was heir to one of America's wealthiest
families
his name was afraid I haven't been a
very good host going school you see
[Music]
sorry how's the pooping good work
sleep well I most like to kill you in
the morning